foreign
[Music]
Smith in a brand new jacket look at this
[ __ ] look at this
you know like he's always running that
purple Jack of that [ __ ] dick well
not anymore now this Dick's in a gray
jacket deal with it week two
of Jay and Silent
clerks three
the convenience tour ladies and
gentlemen what it look like if I could
be there you're saying I can't go
I can't [ __ ] be bothered with their
[ __ ] all the time I'll see it on
Home Video but I'm curious what was it
like you're about to find out ladies and
gentlemen take a look at what week two
of the convenience tour was like Josh so
I woke up this morning whenever I'm in
Vancouver smoke a joint look out on the
city and feel like oh my God I remember
when I first came here 30 years ago and
it's so intimidating and [ __ ] and now I
return and I'm showing a movie here is
great it was very early so I wanted to
take like a [ __ ] walk and I wanted to
pick up sneakers because all I had were
my Vans and [ __ ] so I walked in in these
Vans across the Canby Street Bridge
which is what I used to do to go to
school because I lived on the other side
and stuff so I walked across the bridge
and [ __ ] and I went Stoner shopping at
Canadian Tire uh
the only place open at nine o'clock that
might sell sneakers
looked online I was like oh [ __ ] they
sell sneakers I can't wait so I went in
and stuff and you know no Canadian Tire
they literally have everything I went
looking for the sneakers took me 20
minutes to find them had to ask somebody
like do you have sneakers they're like
Canadian Tires everything and they
pointed me
to where the sneakers were so I'm
rifling through looking for sneakers and
[ __ ] and uh a sales associate uh comes
in the house can I help you and I was
like yeah I was I was looking for uh
nine and a half uh in in any kind of
walking sneaker and he's like oh we
don't do half sizes and I was like
really I was like that's so everything's
just on the uh on the regular size he
goes uh yeah why where are you from and
I was like I was like I didn't know what
this had to do with anything but I was
like originally from New Jersey but now
I live in California and it goes oh that
explains it you think you should have so
many choices this is not American tired
duly noted Timbit [ __ ]
so I just walked in town walked over to
Camby bridge and kept walking and [ __ ]
like that and went three miles up and
then I was like all right let's go three
miles back as I was coming back I saw it
was like 10 in the morning or a little
before 10. it was like 10 to 10. there
was a massage joint open and I [ __ ]
felt like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna get my
calves worked on and stuff
so I go in and uh the lady's like you
want a full massage and I was like why
because it's early like I I didn't
understand her confusion I was like uh
yeah I would like full massage I said
but I keep all my clothes on
and she goes why
and I was like I got body shame issues
and she goes what does that mean I was
like I I have a little dick doesn't
matter I
I just I feel more comfortable keeping
my clothes on and she goes uh okay and
she named the price and the price was
very high so I was like oh isn't there
like a menu of things I could choose
from like that that sounds like more
than I wanted and she's like no it's
this and then there's a tip and I was
like right but what am I getting for
this is a footwork or is it leg work
and she goes you want full massage right
and at this point I realized we were in
a negotiation for sex
and I was like oh God no no no not not I
want to fold the massage not full
massage and she goes you want an actual
massage
and I was like yeah yeah and she's like
oh okay go ahead lay down and so
thank you
I laid down with the utmost assurance
that everything was going to be cool
somebody else [ __ ] came in a
completely different woman that I was
dealing with and she's like Hi how are
you I was great she's like you really
want a massage
and I was like yeah yeah just I've been
walking and stuff mostly on my legs and
stuff she's like all right and then she
starts massaging me she's talking to me
telling where she's from and stuff like
that and she's doing my legs and she's
you know doing uh like my calves then
doing on my thighs and then doing
awfully inseam on my thighs while still
talking about where we're from and [ __ ]
like that and then finally she goes uh
so no happy ending
and I was like no God no no happy that I
mean in life yes but here
no no happy ending necessary she's like
you sure and I was like I'm I'm like I'm
so I'm positive look I got one of these
like [ __ ] Wonder Twin powers activate
and I can't
no one is allowed to touch my dick
except this person and [ __ ] and so she
was like okay
so you know got done paid and left and
instantly started calling everybody I
know
part of the story that like affects me
the most
every one of them every one of them was
like did you do it
including my [ __ ] daughter
told her she goes ew and I was like in
that [ __ ] weird she goes did you do
it and I was like what the [ __ ]
I feel like oh my God a [ __ ]
projectile went out thankfully it died
right there but it was going for your
little boy
how old how old are you 11.
gonna have to guard everything I say now
no not at all oh [ __ ] you were come when
we made the first movie
[Applause]
when we made the second movie you were
still coming it's crazy
welcome to the clerk's averse my friend
you'll explain what com is later on
there was there's the week you missed or
you were there and you were like I
remember I saw myself in the [ __ ]
audience and [ __ ]
um but maybe you didn't see yourself in
the audience and you're like my God I
wish I did see myself in the audience
there's one way to rectify that ladies
and gentlemen clerks3 dot movie
get tickets come watch clerks three with
me on the convenience tour man it's a
blast every night it's like going to a
[ __ ] Tent Revival
and I'm like one of those corrupt
ministers that takes all your money
gives you a [ __ ]
half a helping of faith
takes himself full helping
of your hard-earned money
Joy
that's what waits for you here on the
the convenience store sorry an itchy
nose and I know some people out there
like what are you Cokey no clearly not
but my nose is itchy so I don't know
what that [ __ ] means
I don't know what to do about it
it's not covet don't say that
uh there it is kids for uh for
come to the community story
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]